Hello Freak bitches saw that his majesty thing,
right?
You saw that,
huh?
Oh,
you haven't seen this.
So University of Michigan,
like a lot of universities.
Yes.
Now doing this,
uh,
you know,
like you sign up for class,
your professor sends out an email to the entire class and professor Joe Rogan,
my preferred pronouns are he him.
And then this one kid was able to cause you can voluntary choose your pronoun.
He was like minus his majesty of it.
What a good kid.
His whole thing was to a point out the absurdity of it,
but then people are like,
you're a fucking asshole.
Like they're all mad at him.
Now his name is grant Strobel.
Chairman of the young Americans Foundation do use the new policy to update his
preferred Pronoun to His Majesty.
How could they be mad at him?
That is,
that is no more ridiculous than h.
I.
R of course there's like 18 different gender pronouns now we've been identified
and we also know there's astral gendered.
If you're feeling like you're part of the cosmos or eat Polly,
I'm Pauline by.
Yeah,
you put it on your,
your pot.
You put it on his podcast or he's a Twitter page like a,
it was like by awareness day and then,
and then some,
some guy,
a real professor was tweeting and he retweeted.
It wasn't something that was so close to parity.
What the fuck did he say?
He was just like,
it was the wording of it was too absurd to even recall.
But it was like,
remember when you're the teacher today on,
on um,
by awareness day,
your gender and your to be by is not to be gender specific,
but your specific to city of your gender can also dictate what your sexuality
might be like.
What,
like something like that.
Something,
I dunno.
And then it was like happy by awareness.
You know,
I finally used an all gender restroom in Portland and it was at a gay bar and I
got,
I didn't enjoy it.
And it's not because of the whole Pronoun thing.
It's because you've got like dude's taking gnarly shits next to you.
That's an issue.
I don't need it.
Yeah.
I don't need it zooms or is A's I'm and by,
and I'm also fluid gender.
My favorite thing is to be fluid gender because you can go however you're
feeling in the moment,
but you have to,
people have to know what to call you,
so you have to,
that's my favorite.
Announce constantly that we want.
We saw this video of this guy who was like,
he was like,
you know,
you should really respect people's pronouns,
which,
which I owe.
I'm like,
okay.
Then he goes and if you see somebody and you're not sure,
just ask them.
Be like,
Hey,
what's your pronoun?
To which I say,
no,
you fucking don't.
Like,
you're not going to just see somebody and be like,
Hey,
hey,
I'm just wondering.
She pronouns.
I think that the elders should be on the person.
The Steven Crowder.
Steven Crowder has a fucking hilarious video where he actually does this and
he'll go,
yeah,
he goes out and asks people what their preferred gender pronouns are.
And they,
there's the,
the looks they give him,
like he goes to like grown adults and it goes up to them on the street and just
talks to them and just wonders what their preferred gender Pronoun is.
Nobody knows what the fuck you're talking about.
Preposterous.
I can't wait for the backlash is what's that video of that Guy Dustin?
Dakota.
Yeah.
We'd have to show Joe that one.
Dakota is amazing.
Did you even see the thing?
Yeah,
to code is incredible.
This Zinzer Zinzer there's a,
Oh for the,
the different gender pronouns.
Why is it so hard?
Why can't you just do what they ask?
My pronouns are not preferred c and the thing is like,
I feel like there's enough people going okay,
really that it's kind of a legitimate thing to not be 100% on board with us.
You know,
cause I feel a little like,
oh,
am I on the wrong end of history are not preferred.
Ask a gender terrorist.
There you go.
Whoa.
This is the newest video on my Oscar gender terrorist playlist on my channel.
Are we allowed to play this without,
Huh?
Yeah,
you can't.
You can't just play it.
Well,
we're not showing it on youtube.
Are we like picture in picture about take it off.
Yeah,
take it off.
It's this dude's,
there's dude.
Whatever it is that's got a beard.
Not,
I know it doesn't have a preferred gender pronoun.
Well that's what you're looking at.
We're going to get to,
so that's the thing now,
right?
You can kind of be whatever you want to be.
Yeah,
which is fine.
I guess I just think it's funny that some people are saying that you should see
this individual and lead with like,
it's like almost like it's rude for you to assume,
which I think is absurd that you're going to,
that it's rude to assume like if you,
if you're going to dictate a different pronoun,
I think that should be on you.
Like a status.
Like you should just show people or some people do have these little stickers
that they put on my preferred gender Pronoun is.
That's cool.
Well,
here's a radio lab and this is one of my all time favorite ones.
There's a radio lab podcast.
They take it so seriously because it's radio lab and uh,
there's a guy on it who's clearly out of his fucking mind and he goes back and
forth between male and female.
He switches while he's talking to you because I just switched.
I just switched.
I'm the man now.
And you're like,
well,
okay,
when do you get to be a dragon?
Do you get to read minds when this book tell the future?
Then we're supposed to respect this.
You have to because it's,
it has to do with gender.
So if this guy was telling you about his past lives,
you know,
as a Roman gladiator or if he was telling you about the future when the star
ships land,
you would think that he's a crazy person.
Right?
But I think it right now,
but we did talk about gender.
As soon as you start talking about gender,
you,
you really,
you're supposed to like give people the benefit of all doubt.
Like even if you think you're switching gender back and forth as you're talking,
like the idea that you're your genders,
like some sort of a seesaw,
you're on the precipice and you can just go left or right to left or right and
it is you just close minded asshole.
You just decide.
Yeah.
You don't understand Joe.
But here's the thing,
are we different a lot of the time?
Yes.
Why can't be expressed in gender like you the other day when you're cranky
because you didn't get your sugar.
Yeah,
right?
Yeah.
Like what dance,
right?
You have a different personality trait.
You fell into this bitchy it doesn't like but doesn't like that.
That feeling that the going back like sexist and need a fire join up jetboat
phobic nervous.
Well,
I'm looking forward.
I'm looking forward to ignoring so many emails that are going to come into my
inbox about this conversation,
but too,
but people get mad.
Oh,
I know they're going to get so mad.
My point is like,
we've talked about this,
like if you're feeling particularly lovie dovie right,
you're the pet and kittens and you're,
you're putting your daughter's hair in ponytails.
[inaudible] it's a more feminine feeling.
So did you switch genders at that moment?
No.
You still specifically,
this guy wanted to go back and forth to being recognized as a man and then
recommend the middle of the conversation and then as he goes back and forth,
he becomes a totally different person.
Like,
yes.
Like he's not going to tolerate any bullshit.
I think usually in the military too.
I was like,
it was like,
hmm.
There's a lot of weirdness to the story.
And he's under the care of a psychiatrist though,
right?
No,
no,
no.
He's wondering around getting government grants and great.
Oh Wow.
I have no idea.
I have no idea what he's doing.
But um,
I just,
you never go.
Like if someone goes back and forth and pretends to be Hungarian,
I'm Hungarian.
No,
I'm not.
no,
no.
I'm from Ireland right now,
but I feel today I'm now I'm Hungarian again.
Right.
I'm identifying that way.
But
fine.
Like,
here's the thing,
if you want to identify throughout the day,
sometimes I am more masculine.
When I'm at the comedy store performing,
I am very alpha male.
I'm very,
it's macho,
but I do,
I have to demand that people know what to call me at every given moment.
That's a little unrealistic.
What's a new thing?
I mean it's so presumptuous.
A narcissistic that you should know what to call.
Does this person at least say like right now,
address me as her,
right?
Yeah.
My shooter for names.
He looks snip and you just see the shit out of them.
Depending on who I'm,
I might be mis-gendering or not depending on how he here or she hears it at the
moment when you get points,
if you're in a conversation with that person,
yeah.
Would you cope like you feel like that's a respect,
like something that you'd be like,
oh,
okay,
I'll,
I'll respect your wishes.
I'm not changing your gender.
You gotta pick one.
Yeah.
If you say,
girl,
Oh,
okay,
you're a girl.
I'm cool with that.
I don't have any problem with that.
But you can't go back and forth.
Yeah.
Okay.
Where I can't talk to you.
Yeah,
it's too much work is in other words.
Yeah.
I think that's the whole thing.
It's too much fucking work.
And if you're an adult,
it's got a full life.
How the fuck are you have room in your head for the Zim Jerseys every second
changing.
Well,
not only that,
that's somebody else's issue.
Right?
What about yourself?
You know,
I don't have any,
I don't even be room to communicate with you because you're concentrating on
yourself so much.
You want people to change how they address.
You just can you just change how you feel occasionally and not have a new
fucking name three o'clock in the afternoon.
Now I'm Bob.
Why did we have to label it every moment of every,
well,
it's a super self indulgent thing and that's what you're getting out of this and
that's what like the people that are,
you know,
they're being labeled as insensitive.
Like that's kind of the point.
The point is like,
yeah,
you're supposed to be insensitive of nonsense.
This deserves a fair amount of mockery.
The Fairmount afraid to in part because we're going to get shamed on Twitter.
People are going to call us phobic of this and that.
Even if you say something remotely on politically correct or whatever.
Yeah.
Look,
there's a bunch of people out there that are just not happy and they might not
be happy with the gender.
They might not be happy with the way they look.
They might not be happy with how old they are.
They might not be happy with a bunch of different things,
but we have like rules as far as like what you can change and what you can't
change and we're allowing people now this is like a really recent thing to just
decide to change your gender,
which doesn't affect me.
I want people to have freedom,
doesn't bother me,
but what?
What is this?
There's an addendum to the radio lab story.
She made them edit out the references to her actually changing her identity.
I guess she stopped,
she stopped switching after all this right here and she no longer flips.
Interesting.
Hmm.
She now remains comfortable as a queer trans woman.
What does,
what does that mean?
What's like,
it's not queer.
There's not gay though.
No,
I thought it meant that queer is like weird.
Like you can do both,
right?
Isn't it?
What does queer then let,
how do you
know gay is gay?
Queer is not gay.
Queer.
It's like non defined.
Okay,
so and not a non defined trail on binary.
That's Tom's domain.
Tom,
can you explain this?
I mean basically,
well you guys,
you fall on the binary spectrum.
Cisgendered privileging.
Okay,
here we go.
Shit.
A queer feeling.
Nope.
That's not it.
A homosexual.
No,
no.
See they're using a different,
now see it used to be homosexual,
but it's not just a homosexual anymore.
Okay.
Terms and definitions.
Lbgt right there.
Click on that one.
Lgbtq now.
Oh No,
there's an I and an a in there to look at that.
See,
look at that.
Make that largest fucking shitty.
Ask you read it.
Bisexual,
transgender credit.
Yeah,
look at it.
But look at above.
Above,
above the top loop.
LG,
LGBT,
ga.
What is TB?
Lg.
Queer.
Asexual,
queer or asexual or questioning and asexual or,
but there's intersexual too.
There's I,
some people choose.
I wait,
what's that?
What does that all,
no,
let's get to Q queer,
Intersex as Jamie,
an umbrella term used by l g B t Q.
A people to revert to the entire L.
G.
B t community and alternative that some people used to queer is the idea that
labels and categories such as lesbian,
gay,
bisexual,
etc. Similar to the concept of Queer of gender queer.
Oh,
okay.
Gender.
Queers different.
Hmm.
What's Gender Queer?
I think that'd be like me.
Like nonbinary don't fall under the spectrum of male or female.
Gender Queer is a term which refers to individuals or groups who are queer or
problematize what they're making,
a fake words,
hegemonic notions of sex,
gender,
and desire.
In a given society,
gender queer people possess identities which fall outside of the widely accepted
sexual binary.
You're not mine.
Your area,
your gender queer,
Bro.
Yeah.
Gender Queer.
Jan Mueller may also refer to people who identify as both trend,
gendered end queer.
I individuals who,
Huh?
This is a lot of work,
man.
That's a lot of work time.
This is what you do when you don't chop firewood.
Yeah.
She was a fucking easy to get water.
It's too easy.
Just get bottled water too easy society.
We have to invent all of these things now and they didn't have taken that
Muskrat shit in my mouth.
This is a real hate mail episode.
We always bring the hate the gender stuff this time.
You know what the real gender stuff though.
No,
no,
no.
The fake stuff.
No,
not the legit people.
They're like,
dude,
I'm a,
I'm a man trapped in a woman's,
but that I do obviously.
Right,
but just keep yourself,
take your weird shit.
That shit suppressors.
Exactly.
Persons good.
I'm telling you the 1950s not all bad.
No,
but you know,
there was,
keep on the right track.
Gender people pour in the turn of the century,
the turn of the 20th century.
There's a lot of photos of transgender people from back then.
It's always been a thing.
I used to see them more and in Hollywood where I live there about 15 years ago,
I just don't buy the going back and forth.
Sorry.
Yeah,
I,
yeah.
I don't,
I don't think most most people do.
I think it's an attention seeking,
uh,
some something,
something else is going on there.
I think not all your feelings should be acknowledged by agree.
That's important.
Right.
I agree.
That's important.
You like this.
The guy wants to be the six year old girl.
I mean,
they have all these specials on him and now he's 57 years old.
I can't,
they don't have specials on him because he's an extraordinary story.
They have specials on him because you know,
it's ridiculous and you're going to watch it.
Yeah.
It's funny.
Yes.
Yeah.
It's weird.
You,
you'll let,
you can't go back in time.
Right.
You lived a long time.
You have to be responsible.
You have a special on him.
The same reason they have a special on a lady who doesn't cut her toenails.
Like,
these are my special name.
It's so true and I can't get a job.
Right.
And they can never get a job.
That's the downer.
Nowadays,
people are employable.
That is the one common denominator.
Okay.